hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 and today is November
14 2007 which makes it my 32nd birthday
and I don't know about you but I just
absolutely hate the number 32 and I
hated the number 31 before that and then
number 30 before that so this year my
most feared and angered and hated number
is number 32 I'm not sure if you're like
me out there but if you get older and
feel sad because there's so many things
you want to accomplish then you're
exactly built from my cloth from my
village I hate getting older I dislike
my birthday I'm not a guy that likes to
get presents I like to give presents
there's nothing I want it's not gonna
have everything it's just there's
nothing I want and if I want it I go and
get it it's not about material things
it's just about getting older and
knowing that the sand is ticking
you know just the sand is ticking that's
kind of funny but you know time is
ticking away and there's so much to be
done and so many people I care in love
and I always fear that one extra day and
especially when I hit your birthday is
one day closer to something that you
don't want to happen you know and 32 is
especially dangerous and and tough you
know 32 this is about 32
okay Simpson more 32 do I really have to
say more and Karl Malone and Kevin
McHale two basketball players that I
absolutely hated and what about 32 what
kind of number is 32 I mean if 32 is so
good then why is it the first number
caught off the calendars I mean if 32
was such a good number wouldn't there be
32 days in a month it's the first bad
number in that thought process I'm just
really struggling but I will tell you
web 2.0 technology has made it a little
bit better
I am beyond humbled by all the Facebook
love I'm getting by the Twitter love by
the mass amount of emails and you know
there's clearly a better way to
celebrate your birthday in 2007 than
with letters 15 or 20 years ago it's
nice to be able to keep in touch with
all those people and you want to thank
everybody but I'm still darn angry I
hate getting older and I'll see you
later